you've been uh youtubing independently
since october
october yes how has it been being
independent
um
well it's really
fun yeah i'm having fun of course but um
it's really busy but yeah yeah i made my
first merch oh
october it was my debut merch
it was really hard i
i hired a manager for the first time in
my life i didn't know i'm gonna do that
my daddy is so so surprised i told him
that i hired a manager what the [ __ ]
anime girls need a manager
every anime girl needs a manager yes
father this is 2021. 2021.
i guess 20 20. is the merch still on
sale or
uh it's not on sale um
right now
but it sold well oh
i wish i could make a real great
keyshawn gunpla
real what
yeah i'd be down for buying a case on
gunpla you said yeah seriously that's
that's the next statement that's the
next stage because plenty of youtubers
have figures now no one has gunpla you
know
you know owning a waifu isn't enough you
need to build you got to build it you
got to build it
it makes the the intimacy yeah stronger
it's like i built her
yeah because i mean
you know when you started individual i
think you are i think you you know blew
up pretty quickly um did you expect the
reaction that you got from doing
individual tubing oh no no no no
i i
honestly i
i didn't expect anything
right it happened i was like
i mean yeah because especially now like
the individual is so massive right it's
so insanely competitive like
it's like getting like new v tours
coming up like 10 v2 words in a day yeah
exactly
yeah it's crazy yeah it's crazy to see
people use dreams debut streams
every day yeah i feel every time i go
into twitter like another one of my
friends is becoming a vegan yeah
or i see a lot of twitter accounts that
have pre-debut or something oh yeah yeah
that's the one i see now well they're
going to debut but they haven't debuted
yet but they're like
on twitter yeah they they show like like
like a two second clip yeah yeah they're
they're they're saying like they're
preparing yeah i see a lot of those it's
like three days till debut or something
yeah yeah a lot of those that's just
like the magic word debut like i said
you know right like we have like [ __ ]
outfit debuts now we go yeah what else
can we like do what else can youtubers
do like
like updated
you did that right you got a new model
made right from the original this is my
model 3.0
i saw a model that was quite interesting
uh where you just had half of your body
what was going on with that how where
did that idea come from have you seen
this what is it do you want to explain
this model i'll let you explain it i
don't want to explain explain it to the
boys um
you've seen the one with my my with
this is so genius from you i have to say
this was big brain this was so smart i
used my camera and well i i i didn't put
i didn't want to put my makeup on so um
i cut my head off and then wore the same
costume as my model because i had them i
had the costume i made the costume
myself and then made the model oh okay
yeah so i had the same one so why not
just put my head off
so it's so small you had like her head
was like here and then you could just
see her chest
and i was like okay so what are you
doing
it was so juicy i remember seeing that i
thought that was photoshopped yeah i
thought that was like meme fan accounts
just uh making that i did a stream
i can do it now
that was that was genius i have to say i
was i was very impressed by that i
thought that how has nobody thought of
that that's so big bro but some fans
hated it wait why are they hating
i don't know my japanese fan like um i
said before um doesn't like uh to see
the real
[Laughter]
for lack of a better way of phrasing
this is they're scared of real boobs
no it's not like that they just get it
they want to keep the fantasy i think i
see so yes
so yes
just like that it's like that uh real
boobs all out that clip from the
simpsons where uh smithers is in the
club and the women are like
sorry i'll show you later this week
yeah what was so strange though that
they would get angry like angry or just
they didn't like it some people got
really angry
because i guess it like breaks the
illusion right why would they get angry
about it though maybe just dislike of it
i can understand but like getting upset
over it feels like so stupid
yeah
yeah yeah
i'm glad you agree i'm glad you agree
i'm like what the [ __ ] it's a weird
thing to get angry about to be honest
what you should do is you should just
like slowly lead them in so maybe how
like start off with 10 3d other than
like 20 3d and then like maybe they
didn't like it because i went all the
way yeah yeah oh yeah so like every
stream you do just like take off like a
pixel do 50 50. right down the middle
down the middle down the middle
and you'll be like harvey too faced like
yeah like a like a movie poster
i just try that
next i want to make someone mad with
that yeah let's do that
i guess i guess it's like the same logic
of like you know uh
like
people who love say for example like an
anime character right but they separate
the anime character from the voice
actress right yeah they want to keep it
separate
yeah um because they want to because
they want to think to themselves oh this
2d character is an actual like real
character not not played by anyone but
it's like a real thing right and like
it's that fantastic i understand it's
gone no i understand that in uh an anime
setting yeah yeah because you know these
lines are recorded and they are then
given two set characters right but when
you're streaming i feel like it's
different
it's always a person yeah i still feel
that there's a lot of japanese viewers
who haven't
differentiated between the two though i
just don't understand how you could
because the whole appeal of the the you
know if they wanted to be obsessed with
just 2d models they would just go and
watch anime but it's a 2d model you can
interact with through the chat right
that's that's where the selling point is
for a lot of people so when you do do io
streams is it that your western audience
that gives you a more positive reception
yeah
definitely definitely yeah okay
because uh i i think we have i think the
phrase here in like the western
community is uh touch grass
that's referring to what guard i don't
know
that's what we talked about referring to
japanese viewers no no that's what we
tell each other when people are too far
off the deep end yeah they can't tell
reality from fiction right yeah before
you decided to become
be tuba cason
was there a point where you were like 50
50 or you weren't sure whether to go
like irl or was it just you're like nah
i'm going to go read tuber right away
there's no doubt in your mind
[Music]
let me say i'm still struggling
going back and forth with that real life
and v tubing what should i do um because
some people really like my real live
streaming and some people hate it and
some people really love my youtubers
yeah their streaming and
art there's there's um i don't know it's
tough
[Music]
i don't know what to say i
there's a bunch of people watching right
now so um
like um i think you'd be honest about it
yeah yeah you could be honest
to be honest yeah to be honest it's
really easy for me to use this model
to do the uh real life because my
my face is always messed up and my room
is really messy i do not want to film in
there so i would disagree but yeah
i don't think your face is quote un
messed up yeah i i i i i do i do relate
to the messy room i know me when i wake
up it's so messed up
you got beat up like what hey point me
to someone who is not messed up in here
that's everything i wanna everyone looks
messed up in the morning you know i
would say in general
just do which one you think you you can
keep doing for the longest time yeah you
know i i used to do only
uh [ __ ] oh my god you used to only do
like sebastian from black butler you
know sushi
my channel the way i started my youtube
channel was i used to just do his voice
in like english sound really posh
english and all my videos are me just
like prank calling places
uh as sebastian i remember back in those
days back in the days good old days like
call people like this yes i suppose i'm
really british oh dude the og fans are
creamy right now
but that's what he sounded like in
english right so um yeah i did that for
a very long time but then i was getting
to the point where i was like you know
what i don't i don't think i want to be
a character anymore i think i just want
to be me i think i think i i want to be
me and that was what happened for me so
i don't know you know what i don't think
i will
but you know it was i got a lot of
pushback when i when i started uh doing
uh well not pushback more so that just
no one turned up
nobody wanted to watch that's that's so
normal though like like when you when
you drastically change your [ __ ] that
much right it's like yeah of course
which means you're not a butler in real
life what is this what is this
unfortunately not but i wish who makes
the coffee
the intern
[Music]
the real bottle the real butler
um but yeah you know it's i'd say if you
have any if you you know if you if there
is a part of you that's like yeah dude i
would like to do more i'll stop i'll
just go for it like
there will there's always push back in
the start but
you know you will gain the audience of a
new
people who appreciate you can't please
everyone that's what i want if you're
considering it
i wouldn't i wouldn't let
never ever ever let the viewers what
they want decide what you want to do
it's your life not theirs right well
that's so true i love you viewers though
by the way uh
yeah sorry we don't talk about anime but
clearly clearly uh we've made that
choice not to exactly exactly you know
if you if you're doing content that is
to appease someone you're not making the
best content you can make you're making
content that you think is the best
content and it's totally gonna like
you're only gonna be able to do it for
so long until you get to that point
where you just wanna you know throw
everything away and be like [ __ ] it i
don't wanna do this there are some times
in the venn diagram where they overlap
and what the viewers want and what you
want right right right that's just
absolutely weird
absolutely everyone's happy yeah happy
little accident yeah unfortunately
doesn't happen yeah yeah the only
problem is that i've been there it's
like this
it's tiny